Millennial moms,
your children do not need to fit into your aesthetic.
Do you see these?
I'm folding laundry right now,
and I fold these every single time
because these are always getting washed,
because they are always getting worn.
These are my sons Paw Patrol jammies.
He is obsessed with them.
He loves them.
They make his day.
I don't know what he's gonna do when he doesn't
fit in them anymore,
cause I'm gonna have to find ones that
are just like this
because they make him so happy
and old. Me, like,
before I had kids,
I would have laughed at this.
I would have said,
absolutely not.
We are not buying this.
Your clothes are gonna be cute.
Your clothes are gonna be neutral.
It's a lot of moms are doing,
and you are robbing yourself of so much happiness.
Just give in.
It's so fun to just give in
and let them buy the Mickey Mouse shirt.
Let them buy the Pokemon backpack,
the ugly, crazy
wild colors.
Buy it for them.
Watch how happy they are.
It's so cute.
It's way cuter than neutrals.
Way cuter. Besides,
we all know that we're gonna look back in,
like, 20 years from now and think
that all the neutral color stuff is ugly anyway,
so might as well have fun.